my name is Andy Schneider and I'm
professional photographer Tom Jonathan
Britain l and I do video production and
we're Burger fiction we're making a
video called Austin point of view it's
going to be featured at South by
Southwest and so we thought you'd be
really cool to show Austin where we live
and hopefully a way but you know you
maybe never seen it before part of the
challenges trying to find a new take on
it and something that maybe is a little
bit different I mean the capital a
perfect example we have to include it
because you couldn't have Austin without
our capital building so we said you know
how can we get this in a way that feels
creative and fun and like it has the
same voice the rest of the video so
that's where you know we attach our
camera to the frisbee and we throw the
frisbee and oh there's the capital
building right there shooting was great
overall given that we were shooting in
between thunderstorms and we probably
ended up getting some things that are a
little bit different or more unique
because of the rain and cloud cover we
tried to use that as much as we could to
our advantage for me it was on the third
day of getting rained out in a row there
was a moment where we even talked about
like should we just like change this
entire idea to somehow involve rain the
nature of how we work in video editing
in general we need something is powerful
enough to handle the workload but to
we're mobile like we were at coffee
shops we work from home and we are on
location this stuff is so the hardware
that we're working with needs to be you
know super mobile when we're sitting
here in doors waiting for the rain to
clear up we are editing and then as soon
as it does clear up and we have the bag
ready to go we like jump in the car we
head downtown immediately nice to have
the flexibility for sure as a creative
person there's always something more
that you could do you can tweak
something you could edit so at some
point you just have to say
done
in the beginning at 2015 we were like
we're gonna make a video every week and
then now here we are in 2016 and they
have like it behind us screen and
there's gonna be other people here and
stuff that's super cool yeah it is
really cool to see our work on a big
screen kind of in a public place like
this you know usually we're like
checking on our phone or whatever so
this is just kind of cool to see it in a
completely different desire